both Korea says it is on the brink of
war because of actions by the United
States in an interview with CBS News
overnight one of the country's top
officials accused the Trump
administration wanting to annihilate
North Korea tensions are rising as the
North gets ready to mark the most
important day on its calendar tomorrow
the day its founder was born 105 years
ago dictator Kim jong-un has been
putting on elaborate displays a u.s.
Navy Strike Group is sailing toward the
Korean Peninsula ahead of a possible
North Korean nuclear test this weekend
Ben Tracy is in Pyongyang where he spoke
to the government official who warned
about the growing risk of a military
confrontation Ben good morning good
morning we sat down with North Korea's
vice minister for foreign affairs for a
40 minute long interview in which he did
not mince any words he says if provoked
by the United States North Korea is
ready and willing to fight a war and
that its nuclear program is not
negotiable Vice Minister Han Seong
Yeol's says the situation between the
United States and North Korea is the
worst it's ever been in one word Trump
is openly pursuing a policy to
annihilate North Korea by force of arms
he calls president Trump's decision to
send a Navy strike force to the Korean
Peninsula
as well as continued US military
exercises in the area provocative acts
do you believe the United States wants
to attack North Korea if the u.s. comes
up with a dangerous military option then
the first card is in our hands we'll
deal with it with our preemptive strike
This Means War so you're saying if you
feel that North Korea is going to be
attacked you will use nuclear weapons of
course so far this year North Korea has
conducted four missile launches that
included more advanced technology and
potential long-range capability it is
also expected to soon carry out its
sixth nuclear test in its quest to build
a nuclear-tipped missile
of reaching the United States
on Thursday we saw the country's leader
kim jeong-hoon
open a large new residential
neighborhood in Pyongyang a sign North
Korea believes it can survive further US
sanctions and continue its nuclear
program is there anything that could
happen that would lead you to not do
that impossible
the nuclear test will take place at a
time and place that the supreme
leadership deems necessary now the vice
minister told me that North Korea does
not want a war and that they are just
responding to threats from the United
States I asked him if he thought there
was a peaceful solution here and he
suddenly started speaking in English and
he said you hope for the best and
prepare for the worst
Alex and Tracey doing some great
reporting in North Korea thanks Ben